footage from a cancelled star wars game
is out in the wild february's xbox games
with gold have been revealed and
hyperscape is dying
new footage of the cancelled star wars
1313 has been unearthed by the vault and
it shows off gameplay of the franchise's
iconic bounty hunter boba fett as he
explores several locations while some of
the video shows off the game in an early
stage of production it's still a
fascinating look at some gameplay
elements including exploration of a bar
chasing down targets and establishing
fed's reputation as a no-nonsense gun
for hire star wars 1313 was originally
revealed at e3 2012 and would have seen
players descend into the criminal
underworld of the galactic empire's
capital city coruscant a year later the
project was officially dead after disney
acquired the star wars franchise and put
all ongoing projects on hiatus the
location of the game level 1313
eventually made its way into several
episodes of star wars the clone wars
interestingly fett was reportedly not
meant to be the star of the game as
author jason schreier noted in his book
blood sweat and pixels lucas arts
leadership was instructed by star wars
creator george lucas to replace the
original protagonist with a pre-empire
version of fed this came well into the
development of 1313 after lucasarts had
cast actor wilson bethel established a
backstory for his character and had
spent significant time on his technical
development i have to admit i'm really
impressed by this gameplay especially
considering it's around a decade old it
it looks modern in many ways and reminds
me of uncharted in so many ways and when
you take into consideration that
uncharted writer amy hennig was also a
part of this project
we could have totally had uncharted in
space uncharted mixed with star wars is
there a way i can fund this project so
that like another studio could pick it
up and continue making it just for me
i'm sorry you you can't play it maybe if
you come over my house you could you
could play for like two minutes and then
just watch me play
moving on to free games xbox has
revealed the next batch of free games
for xbox live gold and game pass
ultimate subscribers february's games
with gold lineup includes two xbox one
games and a pair of 360 games that are
backwards compatible there's probably a
good chance you haven't heard of these
games but here they are broken sword 5
the serpent's curse aerial knights never
yield hydrophobia and band of bugs a
runner like ariel knight seems perfect
for my phone a backbone and remote play
so i'm excited to get into that let me
know what you're excited for in the
comments
in other news ubisoft has announced that
it will be shutting down the servers and
ending development on hyperscape it's
free to play battle royale game on april
28th in a statement the company said
quote we set out to create a vertical
close quarters and fast-paced shooter
experience and we're extremely grateful
to our community for joining us on our
journey we will be taking key learnings
from this game into future products
hyperscape launched in august 2020 and
the game's third and final season was
released in march 2021 but the game
hasn't had any substantial updates since
then it also struggled to find an
audience on twitch despite being closely
integrated with the platform viewers
could interact with the game such as
being able to vote on where a match
takes place or what kinds of modifiers
would be turned on
ubisoft concluded their message by
saying quote to the hyperescape
community thank you for your passion and
dedication to the world of neo arcadia
both inside and outside of the game your
devotion to the game we built will
always be cherished to say i was
horrible at hyperscape is a complete
understatement but let me know if you're
going to miss it in the comments and
what you plan on playing instead there's
plenty of battle royales out there so
you've got a lot to choose from and if
the lighting looks a little bit
different because i i kept saying hyper
escape instead of hyperscape
so i
had to redo this part
okay
[Music]
you